the collector is another of em ek
Levin's new characters and I remember
first seeing the reveal and thinking who
and what the hell is that he does have a
very goblin s look to him and I guess
that was the intention because he's race
known as the Ngoc nada are described as
goblin like creatures with six arms
drawing some inspiration from Carly the
Hindu goddess of destruction the Nook
norden's are a completely new race to
the franchise with the collector being
the only one that we see outside of his
ending they do have quite a striking
appearance with blue colored skin orange
colored eyes and six arms four of these
arms are sprouting from their shoulders
and the two smaller arms protruding from
their back that the collector uses to
hold his backpack the backpack itself
does seem to have some quite interesting
magical properties being able to hold
much larger objects inside from weapons
and trinkets to entire bodies the Nook
norden's were enslaved by Shao Kahn and
forced to build the Coliseum and take up
other menial jobs they weren't given
traditional names instead they were
named after the job they do
hence the collector as he was one of
Shao Kahn's primary debt collectors a
six-armed reaper man if you'd like being
born into slavery and poverty the
collector relish the chance to steal the
wealth of others to satisfy his own
endless greed it's this ruthlessness and
lack of compassion for those in a
similar position to himself that caused
him to rise to the ranks as Shao Kahn's
Imperial collector however when Shao
Kahn was killed and Kotal Kahn took the
throne he went into hiding for fear of
reprisal from the people and the new
Khan so now on to the story there will
be spoilers ahead the first time we see
the collector is in the Coliseum where
he's being held in a slave wheel by
several of
kotas men which should give you an idea
of how strong he may be Kotal Kahn then
declares that he will no longer steal
from the people of Outworld in what
looks to be a public execution but our
six armed goblin friend doesn't really
seem to care telling cojo that if he
kills him he will only lose profit
another good indication of the
collectors greedy nature before the
execution Shao Kahn and his forces
arrive displaced from another timeline
in all of the fasting commotion caused
the collector manages to kill a bunch of
the jailers and free himself from the
slave will eventually escaping with the
arrival of Devorah his next interaction
is with Jade who questions his actions
rise into the top from the exploitation
of others to which he justifies by
saying that his people were despised and
nothing more than slaves now as an
enforcer of Shao Kahn his people are
feared eventually Jade and koto were
caught and he escort's them back to the
Coliseum where the roles are now
switched and now it is Kotal Kahn who is
to be executed however much like the
first attempt the execution is
interrupted this time when katana and
her rallied forces stop her father the
collector then blocks off katanas way to
her father doing his best to protect
shao kahn only to be defeated we then
get some dialogue between the two where
he tells katana that she is ungrateful
because she has never experienced cold
and hunger like him or his people if she
had then she would value the life that
her adopted father they gave her katana
then spares him and were left to believe
that he is once again captured in this
scenario he definitely demonstrates his
loyalty to Shao Kahn but if we look at
his ending then we see this loyalty only
really goes as far as his own personal
gain an ending that is actually quite
reminiscent of Shao Kahn himself
chronica made big promises not be enough
though for what my people suffered our
hands built the Coliseum in the palace
we were slaves
we served or we died
every coin I took from Shao Kahn's
tributes Outworld
old my people let my not neuron brothers
and sisters join arms to help me know
every great treasure I have one I have
one myself
I do not wait for handouts I take what I
desire that is why I am now gone never
well air through all the realm chaos
realm I want them all and I will take
them by right of MORTAL KOMBAT